Hello. This is number 20. Christmas tree lecture number 20, I doubt if I fight anybody here except me has been here for all of the previous 19.
But they. But the basic idea is that one of the most important things to computer scientists is trees and that.
And every year I learn at least one really cool thing about trees, and I didn't know before.
And so every year I give a Christmas tree lecture in which I try to explain this as well as they can.
And I thought, wow, I've got to tell you guys tonight.
It's always it's always most fun to give a lecture when you know that you've got a great story.
So I'm going to get right into it. But I'm going to try to get into it slowly so it's not too scary.
Now, we're going to talk a lot about numbers tonight and.
And some I thought, you know, by the time I got 76 years old, I would probably have seen all the really amazing, fairly simple patterns of numbers.
But I was really surprised. And here again, I'm going to show you some new stuff that that blew my mind during this summer.
Well, I guess it was more like October when I when I came across these things.
Now, I'm not the only person in the world who knows these things. However, it was new to me.
And so until I can explain it to you, I have a few new things to say.
I think maybe to end up in order to check out what I do, I'm going to be using computers so you can check the numbers.
You know, not good. And until I, I worked out a set of of RMAC of functions, definitions for for Mathematica, which I'm going to put online.
And. And it called dumb. I mean, you don't have to memorize these.
But I just want to show you that it exists. So so this is going to be online. Online. You'll be able to download it tonight.
And. And so it's called Christmas 20 diadem. And there'll be a link to it.
And so these are bunch of programs that will make Mathematica computes the kind of stuff that I'm going to be talking about now.
OK. This too small to read, of course. But I just want to show you that exist now here.
However, I'm going to zoom zoom in on stuff and.
And so here. Oh. OK. Can you. Can you try to get the largest you can on this on this part here.
OK. Little bit. Oh actually it shows better on on that screen and on my screen.
OK. So here I am.
I'm using this sock, this proprietary program here, and.
And I, I, I first set it up so that the be possible to zoom in without going off the screen.
So you can go. Yeah. That's that.
OK. Here we're doing so. So at the beginning that said options just make sure that you know, I'm not going to make the lines too wide.
Now then the next thing is I input this file. Christmas twenty nine M.
And if you look at the bottom of the file, actually the last line of the file is.
Merry Christmas. Go. Gosper got the joke of one input to file.
It always displays the value of the expression on the last line of the file.
But but Merry Christmas is the product of two variables. Merry Christmas. And it always reorders them in alphabetical order.
So we have so. So anyway, now that's Mike gets my joke for the night.
Next line is be to or what?
What do I mean by that? OK.
So now now I got to tell you, the story of this whole idea of of of trees is not only important, computer science is really important in my life.
I mean, it changed my life when I was a sophomore, when my my teacher gave me a challenge problem.
It turned out the solution to the problem was to find the generating function or to find the Catalan numbers in the Catalan numbers are now so famous.
But if it's a number of binary trees that there are within nodes, what's a binary tree?
A binary tree is either empty or it has a root and and then a left binary tree and a right binary tree.
So square root and in two binary trees or empty.
So the number that the Catalan numbers are, the number of binary trees would end nodes and the coefficient of this of zie.
And those people in Canada will realize that. I don't say Z.
I say Z. This is sick. So one plot.
So B2 is the is function for trees.
Binary trees V three will be ternary tree and 10 says just give me up until order.
Zeder the tenth. So here are the coefficients up.
You know you think an infinite series. But up until the ninth I've got the numbers there that the number of nine node binary trees is forty nine.
Sixty two and forty eight. Sixty two end. And you see there there's one binary, two with one node.
It's just a root. And then there were two. With two nodes and five with three nodes and so on.
Those numbers are some of the most important numbers to me in my life.
Just because I think I've encountered them this time.
OK. Now, in my book, Concrete Mathematics, I have what I call a generalized binomial series,
which includes not only the binary trees, but also the tier three trees for all T.
And so and so that's on page 200 of concrete math.
And we got. Let me see. Good. Can you go down to where I am.
We're on point. Yeah. Here we go. OK. OK. Generalized generalized binomial series.
And it's defined by this formula here. And I, I call a script B, some T of Z.
And and that's the one when you put T equals two. That's the one that we've got for the Catalan numbers in here.
It is. Is it the basic identity that that defines this for.
For any ti it's sort of a polynomial equation when a twenty is a negative.
Integer, but anyway, this is the this is the main equation.
And then on a cut on a couple of pages later, I show you the Catalan numbers.
And so you see there's a simple formula for the coefficient of Zeder, the K does the Catalan number.
And there's a lot of other things going on.
But one of the one of the really great formulas is actually on the previous page where it shows that if you have any TI whatsoever and any power,
there's a simple formula for the coefficient.
So so if I have, you know, eight Aeris trees or something and I want to cube it and I just take two equal eight and Article three and I plug it in,
I get to cook, I get the number of of waves. There are two. I have three eight actin cherry trees.
So that's concrete math, just generalized binomial series.
And I, i that's one of the most used pages in my copy of the book.
So now next thing on the.
On the transcript here is B three nine.
This shows ternary trees. So ternary trees, the same thing.
It's either empty or he has a root and then three ternary trees.
And so these numbers go. One one three twelve fifty five, 273, 14, 28.
Now, I don't know those numbers quite as well as the Catalan numbers, but but tonight I urge you to remember them.
Think about them. These are gonna be great numbers for tonight. Three one one three twelve fifty five to seventy three.
That's it. That's far enough. But anyway, you see a number fifty five. That's pretty easy.
You know the speed limit. And until I'm OK now.
So that's ternary trees. And last year my lecture was about ternary trees, a special kind of ternary trees and a connection with geometry.
Now the basic property of the ternary tree function, which I can call TMZ.
Let's say that this is a script B, three of the V and T t v, it's equal to one plus G times.
TMZ, cute in this generating function, says that it's either an empty case, which means there's no notes.
And that's why I get this one in here, or there's a root node which I call Z.
And three other ternary trees. And as Y T cubed accounts for three other ternary trees.
So solution to this equation is a series in Z that that defines ternary tree.
Now, when I write, I learn a concept in math.
I try not only to generate upward, but the generally downward. I don't know.
Not every mathematician believes in this, but I always like to. I mean, when I learn a two dimensional geometry, three dimensional geometry.
Actually, no. I think I went to four dimensional drama. I said, wait a minute, let me learn one dimensional geometry and zero dimensional geometry.
What is that? You know what I know? What the what the what the volume of of a of a sphere is.
And in four dimension, I knew what it was. What what is the volume of a sphere in one dimension, you know.
And so I had to see what the forms were. So anyway, let's look at B one.
Oh you'll be one of Z.
These are unitary trees, right. That's one plus three times B, sorry.
B, one times B, one of three. And so that's B, it's the solution to the vehicles one plus ZB.
So that's the easiest one to solve. And you, Tozzo, you see that the power series is pretty is pretty easy.
Oh yeah. Zoom in on that. Of zoom in on the computer output for me there.
OK. So, so here we got you know, just one, one urinary tree of, of ten nodes.
It's got a root and it's got another urinary tree upside.
Nine below that. OK. And then of course you've got to go further to and then go to be zero.
What is the what are the null airy trees. And these are they're either empty or it has a root and and nothing below it.
And so it's one plus.
And then I went up here to Begal of Zie to the one hundredth I could have gone up to 1000, but I didn't want Mathematica to compute to our kindness.
OK, now. So. So anyway, you can try other other values.
And the title of my talk tonight is three have very trees. And this is A.
So B, three halves. And here I'm going up to Zeke Zeder the ninth and you'll see that it's one plus zi.
Then there's three halves of of with two nodes and there's twenty one eighths with three no's and five with four nodes.
Turns out well you have to figure out what it means to be half a tree.
But anyway the formula gives us this. And because I showed you that no matter what t was,
there was a simple formula for it using binomial coefficients and even the simple formula we raised to a power, at least we got a number here.
So. OK, so lots of formulas give numbers, but but if they aren't integers, it's hard to interpret what they mean.
And so I got to go look a little further. But but as long as we're generalizing, let's try pi.
Why not. So. So. So let's try.
Piira trees. OK, and well. So it's one plus the plus pisey squared.
And then here is minus pi over two plus three. Pi squared over two and so on.
Finally, when you get into later terms here, it explains it.
It gives it directly in turn to binomial so that you can see it didn't you know,
it didn't even bother to evaluate what this was because it would be harder in other form is so.
So in other words, just if you plug in T for PI, that's what that that's what that's what you get here.
I tried, I imagined three squared of minus one.
And so, you know, I have no idea if if these if this formula has any use whatsoever.
But but if it does. If it does, I propose that we call them imaginary trees.
OK. So I.
I also want to show you ternary trees squared.
Here I went. OK. Only took eight turns because otherwise we'll take another line.
And here there's another set of numbers that keep in mind tonight we're gonna run into this number, these two again.
So this is one two seven thirty one forty three and so on.
Now, this is the number of ways that you can you can have a pair of ternary trees and ordered pair of ternary trees into it.
Square that generating function and.
And here I just calculate binomial coefficient according to the formula in concrete math.
And lo and behold, it gets. I get the same numbers. One, two, seven thirty one.
Forty three, seven, eight. OK, so. So this up.
I got it. Not only in this case, I got it by squaring a series and here I got it by plugging into another formula.
So let's give some evidence that that formula works and it worked for it for any power to change,
to do any number here in in all three places in this formula.
And that would give me any number, number of power of of that thing.
OK. Now, why are the three halves case so interesting?
And I'm going to show you a little a little bit first.
Let's take the three halves degenerating function B, three haves and Ray and take the square root of that function.
So this means I'm not going to have, you know, it let you know, I squared it.
I had two I had two trees. But here I have the square root, which says sort of I have something like half a tree.
In some ways, if I if I if I multiply it just by itself, I have an order ordered pair of half trees.
And that gives me a full tree.
And so, you know, three have very trees is supposed to be a root and and and and one and half other three have airy trees below it.
So. What does a half mean. This might give us give us some insight what it is.
OK. And I'm going to call it G zero for the heck of it. But. And so here's a here's the numbers again.
They're just near some weird fractions. You might notice, though.
Well actually I continue on the next page haha. Yes.
Here I kick your I, I calculated the formula for a way out.
And I kept going and going and going. Still here. You know, the coefficient of zero the twelve to the fourteenth.
And, and you know the, the previous numbers I recognize powers of two like you know two six to one or four.
I've seen the number before but I don't I don't know this one so well.
Three three five five four four, three, two. So I factored it and it turned out that's two to the twenty fifth.
And so this gives me pretty good evidence that all the denominators in this formula of power is a two.
And that turns out not not hard to prove with number three. OK.
So now anyway, I got this long formula for the square root of the three have very guy and now I'm thinking I'm going to do the same thing,
but I'm going to I'm going to change Zi to minus Z in the formula.
So we're the previous one started out one plus Z over two plus three have squared and so on.
The new one starts out one minus C over two plus three have then minus all the all the odd powers of ze.
Now have a minus sign out where previously they had a plus sign. That's a different thing.
G one and G zero.
So here we got these two, these two generating functions which represent who knows what, you know over a half of a three have very tree.
But we have to two, two of them, one that has minus signs in it and one has plus 19.
So let's see what happens if we take the product, we multiply the two things together.
Oh, look at that. All integers, all those fractions cancel out and we're just left with it with nothing but integers.
Not only that, look at the integers. One, two, one one three.
Twelve fifty five. No speed limit.
This is. These are turn. This is the ternary tree. This was for some reason I put together two of these half guys and I at one with the square root,
with the minus the one of the Plessey with all kind of fractions in there.
And and I got ternary trees out of it. OK, well, that was the product of the two.
Let's try the different. Yes, one, two, seven, thirty one, forty three.
This is the square of the ternary treat function as the other.
That's the other sequence that I said is going to be one of our favorites tonight.
OK, so it looks like we've got a conjecture here that I mean, I've only calculated out the first 10 coefficients or so.
But all those fractions cancel out. There must be. It can't.
Just be prepared. And so when I saw this, I said, whoa, wait a minute.
This B three halves has to be a much more interesting function than I ever thought before.
Now, in order to understand this connection, then I'm gonna go back to ternary trees and start and start thinking more about ternary tree.
So remind you about ternary tree.
The ternary tree. It can be understood if I draw you a random one here.
So let me let me do one that has six nodes and I'll give it three non-trivial ones at the root.
Then I'll put one. Here is the middle child in here.
I'll put one of the right hand child and then. So.
So this this guy has a has an empty left child. This guy has an empty left in the middle.
This one has empty all three. And so it is this one.
And I can number these, so I'm going to call is later a this guy also has to have his three kids.
OK, so so so there's six nodes and then there are 14 of these hangers-on that represent empty ternary trees and aisle number those zero through 12.
And then I'm going to number the nodes themselves in what we call post order, which means to you, come to this guy first and then this guy.
And then this guy. And this guy. This guy. This is the post order of walking through a tree.
And so anyway, that's left to ternary tree now.
Now, our computer scientists know that ternary that the trees correspond to evaluating algebraic expressions.
And we often do that with a stack. And so one of the tripto.
So if if we are if we think of this expression evaluating it, we say, well, we got to put put numbers in place of these boxes here and then.
And then whenever we do a ternary operation, we combine the three numbers that we've got.
And so if we do that, we put numbers on the stack.
One at a time. And and and then decide the stack.
After we've put put put zero on the thing, we've got one guy on the stack.
Then we put one on. And I got another guy on this deck.
You see though, no one here. If I put two on and three on then I've got now I've got four guys on the stack.
And now we know we evaluate this ternary operation.
So we replace the top three guys on the stack by a. And so I draw a little red line here, says now, Eve.
Now, this deck went from four down to two up. And I've got a is sitting here and then zero and one are still are.
So zero is still sitting here too. So eight and zero are the two guys on the stack up.
Then we put four on the stack and we can evaluate, revaluate, be set.
So then Beas is sitting there as the only guy in this day. And so on.
Every time we we encounter one of these square boxes, we add it to the stack.
Whenever whenever we encounter a a round node, a ternary operation,
we remove three guys from the stack and put it and put the round node on in place of it.
So. So the net is the stack went down by two.
And so what we have here is a is a path that consists of steps that are either plus one or minus two and the number.
And when the first step is always a plus one. But but but the number of ways to get to get back to something.
Now there's only one in the stack. After a certain number of steps is equal to the number of ternary trees, every ternary tree corresponds.
Every ternary tree with six nodes would correspond to another path that goes from here to here.
It would have it would have the right number of of plus ones and the right number of of minus twos in it now.
And then what the main thing is, it never goes down to zero in the stack. Never gets empty.
The stack always has at least one guy on it after we put after we put zero on there.
So so that's that's a connection.
Then that got ternary trees is also equivalent to paths on this one in a in a random walk that has steps of five plus one or minus two.
And so now I got to show you a great paper about such random walks of this list published 2002 Theoretical Computer Science.
And I mention it because I had the privilege of meeting Cheryl Bender in June when I was in in Paris to give a lecture in honor of Ali Flagellate,
who who unfortunately died a few years ago. And and and I hadn't read this paper before.
I knew it existed, but but I didn't know what a beautiful paper was until until later.
And in this paper, they talk about four of the four kinds of of walks that are that are generally studied.
First is arbitrary walker path, which says that you have steps of different possible kinds of steps.
In this case, showing lots of different kinds. But but in my case, I was only considering plus one.
Minus two.
So an arbitrary thing is called a walk, but if it comes back to zero at the end, it's called a bridge, like a Brownian bridge or something like this.
And then and then a meander is a walk that never goes below zero.
And an excursion is a meander that ends up at zero.
So these are the four kinds of walks that.
That are studied and each of them has great algebraic techniques to understand how many there are of that kind.
OK, now. So I'm going to now try to study meanders with steps that are plus one and minus two.
And I'm going to call. I'm going to call it the gender.
Any function, I'm going to call it F of Z. And you were Z is going to count that the length of the path and you is going to count the height and.
And so the coefficient of of Z to the J, you to the K is going to be the number of meanders of length J that end up k.c steps above the above zero.
And so if it starts out at when, when with the empty meander and then there is Z you is it is his manner of length one and we're one step above.
You have a question. OK. And then the length too.
If we had where it at position one week we can't go down to minus one so we have to go up against the only possibility at.
After two steps is is is to be at high two. But at three steps we have to chance it.
We have two choices and it's one plus U. Q. Because we can either come down to zero or go up to three on this step.
OK. Now what about four steps? Well, if we're at zero, then we have to go up.
But if we're at three, we can come down to one or go up to four.
So that gives us actually to you. Plus, you do the fourth.
With me, there are two ways to. There are two ways to get to two.
One of them come up from one. The other come down from three and.
Zero. The fifth. Well, what happens now?
Well, we. I mean, how many ways to get to.
You're going to be something in front of you squared. Any guesses, what, two?
Five to eighty three. OK.
So I can get it after four steps, either add at one or four.
So now I know it's either going to go to two or four or six because I'm either adding one or subtracting one.
So. So if I add one in this case and I get two ways to get there, but if I subtract two from this one.
So. So this is three squared plus you two the fifth.
And and so on and so on.
The next one it turns out is three is three and zero and then four ways you cubed and then you two, the six and so on and so on.
Now it gets easier if I use shorthand to do the count.
I mean, if I keep if I write the coefficient without the Z disease and W Newt.
So so let me just write it this. Let me just write it, you know.
Polynomial. Of the case where we're zero zero the polynomial is just one.
When Ze is one zero one corresponds to you plus zero.
Ze squared is zero zero one. Ze cubed is one zero zero one.
This is one plus you cubed one plus knows.
No use. No use. Square one. And you cubed. Then I get zero two zero zero one zero zero three zero zero one three zero zero four zero zero one.
And you see what, seven zero zero five zero zero one.
You you you can sort of see how I do this byte by just not exactly nite moves.
But I but I get each one by, by we're looking at the line above it and either going one this this way or two that way.
And I add those two numbers together and took until that gives me this expression.
And so now I now I can let the computer do that for me.
And so I, I have it in that, in that file that I can I put online.
I have something that, that evaluates these coefficients which I call C of P,
Q and these are called the are the ternary, the ternary ballot numbers and for TR.
This is ternary trees. But about, you know, any, any kind of trees, we have the corresponding corresponding table of numbers.
And this this is now actually put in I take the wrong volume here.
This table appears in my in my book, The Art of Computer Programing on page the volume for a on page seven nine.
It's one of the most used pages of my book. Again, I keep turning this.
I run into another problem where I need these numbers somehow. So here we see the numbers.
And I want to I want to emphasize so that these numbers are the coefficients that correspond to what I just calculated.
Well, why is that? Well, it's it it's tipped a little bit.
You have to you have to go this way and reflect left to right.
But but we're have one three three here and then I have one for seven and so on in
the book that that went one three three and one four seven one five twelve twelve.
So sick touch the same set of numbers but just stick it know in a in it in this like this guys.
And. And there's formula for S.O.P in Cube.
A couple of formulas. This was the one I liked the best actually. And it's the people usually use this one because it's, it's a single term.
But but here it's is, it's the sum of two terms. Makes it much more clear that why it's an integer.
Because these are obviously integers. Well this doesn't look like it has to be an injured.
Okay. So that's that's what happens in these.
That's what numbers we came up with here. And. But I want to I want to emphasize that.
Let's see if you look at if you look at at the at the extreme numbers at the end of each line here, look look what we have.
First, if I if I go the even numbered lines, I get one one three.
Twelve fifty five. No speed limit. But if I look at the odd number, so, you know, I can put a circle around D.
D number. And if I look at the odd numbers and you put a square note.
That's one. Two. Seven thirty. Hundred and forty three.
Those are the other ones. OK. So. So in fact what's happening is these are numbers that are somehow important to our problem.
Right. And we know also that we have a pretty good conjecture.
This means turn the number of ternary trees. In fact, we know it's a number of ternary trees because because it's a number of off.
Because it's it's the coefficient of when when we have no.
But we don't have a power of you in here. That means that we're at level zero, which is the definition of being a good ternary tree.
And, you know, that makes an excursion instead of a meander. So.
So. So here with one in the one and the three. That's this one, one and three.
And those are the extreme points that I just put a circle around. My formula.
So right now. These numbers than the ternary tree number six seem to be coming up, all right.
And we improved it yet. But but we're but we're we're starting to understand the territory and.
And it definitely seems to have something to do with the with the F f function.
So now let's see.
OK, so now let's remember the definition of F that that I had.
How did I form it formed. For me this. Well when I had Zeder the J.
U to the K then that sort of mapped into on the next step either Zeder the J plus one you do the K minus two.
I'm sorry, you're the K plus one. This means I added one to the height or you do the J plus one the new step.
You do the K minus two. However, this is only allowed if KS is greater than or equal to if case is zero or one.
I'm not allowed to subtract two. So. So this is the rule that I used.
And it says that in a sense, if I have this kind of equilibrium situation, as in this as a business function here I zeder the J.
U to the K minus Zeder the J plus one U to the K plus one minus Z to the J plus one zero the J plus one you to the K minus two is somehow,
usually zero. The coefficient of these things, if it in F is usually zero.
This is Z to the. Whenever I have a coefficient in front of this guy then the same thing has been added to the other guys.
So. So this is Zeder the J you minus two times a polynomial. Here is Utku minus Z, you cubed minus Z.
And this panel is going to be a key to to understanding the function F, because if we multiply F by this polynomial, we're gonna get mostly zeros.
We're gonna annihilate all the stuff. Okay. Now that's not hard to see if like if we look at if we look at it in the following way.
So let's suppose I remember f f avc use is big.
Is this big sum of all the number of ways to disease and use different par with it.
And it starts out as one. And then we take it from zero.
And you and multiply it by Z time you plus one overuse squared.
This means in other words we take every term of F that we had and we multiply it by ZEW.
That means go up one step up. And that was my mocked by baozi overuse squared.
That means go down to when he goes up one you goes down by two.
However, then we have to subtract out the cases where where we weren't allowed to go down to.
So I subtract that. That's that's a function of Z. That's a generating function of Z.
Divided by by use square. This is the case where I was it I where I was at Hyd Zero.
And I want to go down. And then I also have to subtract off the case where I was at height one and one and go down by one.
OK. So. So this is it a way if I, I got two unknown functions here, I have the ability,
but if I knew what they were that would express what this function F is F is the function I'm trying to determine.
And so what this means is that if I it I can rewrite that, that formula this way, I'm doing it in a slightly tricky way.
But you can easily check it with algebra. So I, I, I, I, I brought this term over to the left and I multiplied it by this guy.
This can multiply everything by you squared. So this is you squared minus B of ze U minus AVC.
So, so this is a this is a function.
This, this is an identity. F is unknown. Is unknown.
B is unknown. How am I going to solve this equation?
However, it turns out that there's a beautiful way to solve this equation called the kernel method.
And that's what that one would explain next. So. So f f represents all these.
Meanders and A represents all the ones that end at that end at dusk and zero.
In fact, I can write it down with a Z. It turns out AFSC overseen is the coefficient of you to the zero.
Of half of the EU. This is the case where I I wanted to multiply by CZI over you square, but I couldn't get.
This is is one plus cube. Plus three Zs squared.
Six. Six. And and so on. And B of ze oversleep is the coefficient of a view to the first power in F of Zeehan you.
And so if, if I look at the case you see where were you. The first part occurs.
I get a Z here. And then I get A to A to Z to the fourth there.
And I get what's going to turn out to be seven z2 the seventh and so on.
And our conjecture actually boils down to the fact that this is equal to T of Z cubed.
And this is T of sorry, Z times, T of Z Cube squared.
Now this is the you know, the number X number here is gonna be thirty in.
The next number here is going to be thirteen and then twenty. Fifty five.
This is what this is either that these are the cases where when I was when I was forming this thing,
I had I had trouble because I couldn't fall off the left hand side here.
The one when I when I formed this table, I wasn't allowed to go clear.
The number is one, three and so on. And those are the numbers that I circled and put squares around before.
OK. So now we got we got this equation.
And it has lots of unknowns, but we conjecture what this is.
I put a question mark here, but but I know probably what's going to be.
And now he the right question to ask is, well, wait.
Now, let's take a look at this at this Kubic polynomial here.
It it turns it if it's linear and Zeeb, it is cubic and in you.
And that's the important thing I can solve for I can factor this and find the roots of this polynomial.
I can fight playing the roots of this cubitt polynomial and find out values of you that satisfy this.
So I'm going to. So I'm gonna I'm gonna factor except for what are the roots of the.
What are the roots of this polynomial, ze u cube, minus U squared, plus Z?
So tell me how you could think of Z as a number like five or something like this or or point one or Epsilon or.
But anyway, it's a you're going to be three values of you complex, maybe that that satisfy this and I should be able to express them.
But these values somehow. And it turns out that that's not hard.
And and so I rewrite this equation.
U squared equals Z times one plus you cube.
That wasn't hard. I suspect this equals zero. And so now, Sal, for you, it's Kubic equation.
But I'm not going to do it the normal way. I divide by Z and I call this R, and this is equal to one plus you cubed.
But this is equal to one plus. Here's the tricky part.
Watch this closely. You is equal to you are is equal to you squared over z.
So I can write this as Zeder The three halves are two, the three halves because zii is equal to use.
Go ahead. And if I take that to the three halves power, I get you cubed.
Now, anyway, you don't get to watch it on the video afterward. And that is it.
Is there anybody here beside Bill Gosper guesses why I'm doing this?
I know that now I have shown that are is equal to one plus Zeder, the three hands out of the three hands.
This means are is equal to my three have every function.
B B three halves of of Zeder the three hands.
Because. Because the definition of this function. Yeah.
Yeah. B b the three half of of X is equal to one plus X times.
B to the three halves of X to the three has power and I plug in X equal to the three halves and I get this.
So, so, so here's my. This is great. I know, I, I know that I can factor this cubic polynomial in terms of my, my generalized binomial function here.
It's not for the three have very. No. And this is the reason why these numbers are coming up as we'll see soon.
See. So it's a total now you see you is equal to the square root.
Well, it's a plus or minus the square root of a Z. R R squared is you square overseas.
So you is plus or minus the R.
And so in other words, one of the roots is going to be for example, A squared A-Z times, B three have of the three halves.
The one half power, because I have to take the square root of it.
OK. Well, back to Mathematica. I can calculate I can calculate that guy.
And it turns out here it is. Wait a minute. No, I'm the wrong one.
You know, I. No, I, I didn't. I didn't do that yet.
OK. Well, somewhere I thought I calculated the one half power of this guy, but done well.
Yeah. Yeah. We had that way back like I had would be that would you.
Zero. And I took I took this function out to 16 terms and I took the square root of it at and sold it.
So these are the numbers that I'm getting here, one oh one half five eighths and so on.
Now I'm cut. I'm taking this unplugging and zie to the three haves and I multiplying everything by square.
Dizzee but that that's the same function I'm getting out. So this is what's essentially G of G zero,
but with a little bit of rescaling and then the G one that that we and we calculate it is also is also a root.
And so in that case, we use that, we use the minus squit, the negative square root here.
And I and I sort of think BP three halves of of, you know, much of the other square.
The other three has power here. And that's the that's what happens if we sort of change.
Zero minus C. You get the other the other root of this of this equation.
And so that. So it turns out they're not that. I know two of the roots of I know two of the three roots of this equation.
And so I call this you won't use zero and uses you on. Now I can get the third route in the same way.
And and I'll do that almost the same way and I'll show you that one, too.
Watch this. For the third route, instead of taking you squared over easy, I am trying to solve this equation.
This time I take one over ZEW.
And so I divided this expression by by ZEW cubed, and so on the right hand side, I get one or one over Utku plus one and well I call it S.
And on the right hand side, this is one Plessey cubed. S cubed. One over overused cubed is equal to Xiqing as cubed and therefore S is equal to.
But be three of Zeek cubed. This is the Rick, this is the relation that defines the ternary treat function as one plus something times the cube of S.
And therefore, I you see, I have you is equal. The root is then one over.
Yes. And so that's the third root I.
You two is equal to one over Z times T of uptimes.
B B three of Ze cubed. So so now I've got day I know of all three routes with that guy and.
And in order to prove it, I will. I've calculated that to show you.
And that's no where. OK.
So here. I.
I have the three roots. The first one is called in my notation of this.
Now, this file is called T2 one 215 terms.
It was a zero for the first branch and one for the second branch.
And the third one is one over the case of a four one two with the zeroth branch.
It turns out that you multiply that together and sure enough,
you get exactly what we wanted and divided by zie instead of I mean, these are the these are the product of the three roots.
So we slowly factor out that equation and where it was based.
OK. Now, this actually proves one of my conjecture is because it says that if we have U minus you zero, you minus you one.
These are the two things I call G zero and G one before. And I had conjectures about those.
And it turns out that my conjecture was essentially that that was equal to you.
Squared minus. You say Ze squared, T squared minus ZT.
What I mean is if you look at this, the product of of you zero you one.
That was the first miracle where I quite multiply those two numbers together and I got.
And I got the ternary function. So. So that's this coefficient.
The other one was the sum of these two guys was actually the difference because I was good.
I had had the sign. But but there is where I got the square of the ternary numbers coming in.
And and so, so so this is a conjecture that drop that they would like to show.
But now, if I multiply this by you, minus one over t you off cases, Teege is is the function for ternary trees with Z replaced now by by Zeke.
You multiply this together and what do I get.
I get I z. Sorry.
Let me let me let let me let me go.
So I here I have zie times. Well.
Yeah, that's supposed to be the thing I multiply there, they're together. So let's see what we get.
We get you cubed minus you squared. The coefficient of you squared is Ze squared, T squared, and then plus one over time.
And then then I get minus Z you what.
Minus one. He would say, well I have a minus here. Oh good.
Stay with us. Yeah. So I had minus and minus.
OK then. Then I had. Then when I get to you itself I've got a Z squared D.
So nope. I got a ZT here. ZT and.
So let's see. The.
T minus V.T., I'm supposed to get minus two to.
Yeah. Here's a minus ZT from this, and here's a minus ZT from here because because this is one over tea with that one minus six.
So this this term goes out and then the constant term is Plessey.
And what about this term here? I'm sorry if this term is.
This is T cubed. I got I got something mistaken here, too.
I know. OK. Let's see. Start over.
I'm gonna get you squared minus you Z squared, T squared, minus ZT.
That's what that's all I got for the first part. I'm going to multiply by by an extra Zeien here and I get a zie over t here.
That makes it that that clears some of the some of the Zs.
But I just multiplied that last term by, by a Z.
So now I get. You could here. And then I get minus U squared.
And here I get Z cube T squared plus one over T.
Then I get A plus you and I get Ze squared T minus U squared T.
There, which goes out and then I get a Plessey six times that these squared.
Something's fishy. Let me show you what here.
Upstairs, here. Biggest page, the previous page.
Right there. He squares. He square divided by.
Okay, let me think now. Oh, this was this was part of my problem that I had.
I forgot the Z here because you one is one over zero.
And I only wrote S. That's it. That's the problem. Yeah. Do I.
I forgot the Z here. So some third world is one over Z Times team.
And that explains the whole business. So, so, so now this goes away to one over team.
Everything, everything is going to work. Now is going to come out. I think it's gonna be z. at the end.
So Sokcho Xiu cubed. Except except I have really all I wanted minus you squared.
But that's ok because Z cubed two squared plus one over T is equal to is equal to one.
That's the same as saying z cube t cubed plus one is equal to T.
Which is that. Which was the definition we had. OK. So Plessey.
So. So anyway this proves the conjecture that I that we had, we knew it was true because those numbers were checking up anyway.
That's it. But now it's we still we really haven't tied that in with the meanders.
I only pretending with the roots of this equation. And so, OK, here's the final punch line here.
And that is that is the the important part of the of the kernel method.
So I had I had this equation which I'll rewrite minus the Q minus you completely F of Xu on the left hand side.
That was there was one unknown on the right hand side. We had this equation B you minus.
And now here's the here's that. Here's the point. I can plug in you zero of U.
Equals U zero. On the left hand side and I get zero on the left.
Because. Because this is the root of this guy. And I can also plug in you you one on the left and I get zero on the left.
And so so these are two roots of the right hand side. The right hand side of the polynomial in you is a quadratic polynomial this time molecule.
So so in other words, this right hand side has to be equal to you minus use zero times you minus one.
The only you know you've got the two roots. And so therefore the A and B are actually tied with these, with these numbers.
The numbers in this equation are the A&E that I got from from the Meander problem are
the ones they got the other case were with and B that I got my by my conjecture anyway.
So, you know, in order to not you want to show, you know, what we've done,
I'm going to work a little bit harder problem and it's end but but the methods are gonna be the same.
So I'm I'm going to run through so that you can check it on the web. See, because this is really the beauty.
This is really the clincher. Now, instead of using it, it got instead of using ternary trees and and steps of upside plus one and minus two.
I'm now going to going to consider steps of five plus two and minus three.
So now we're going to do meanders. But every time we either go up by two or minus three, people think of this as a at as.
As a club where people can come come in and at at the beginning of the day, nobody's there.
And at the end of the day, everybody's gone home. But in. But meanwhile, some people come in in pairs, but they always leave in threes.
It turns out there's a designated driver and two other people when they leave.
And so and so we want to know how many ways are there for people to go in and out of this club?
At the end of the day, having so having had so many how many transactions?
And these are this is interesting. Generating function. So so we know we can start out and we and we get F of ZEW before this time.
It turns out to be easy to square the first. After one step.
We have have two guys in there after two steps.
It's how we always have to have four people in there.
After three steps, however, it's it's either one or six because we either subtract three or add two.
And so on and so on. And we start looking at at the coefficients that we get.
Just as I did before. And we get.
A pattern like this. And.
And so on, how we've got a bunch of numbers. Bye bye bye.
This shift over to shift over three rule.
And we get a table of numbers that looks like this. And and the table of numbers can be interpreted in the following way.
Actually, I have I have a chart I forgot to show you for the IV, for the ternary case.
Here we have a graph where I have shown connections, which is a grid with with with parts suppressed.
I'm saying, how many paths are there from this starting point to a given point?
And there are 143 paths from here to here. And the reason is that of fifty five of them go to here in 88 and come to here.
And these eighty eight, fifty five here and thirty three here and so on.
So each you just to easily construct this, if you, if you have any in any kind of a grid,
you can figure out how many ways there are to get to one place to another.
And then the new problem, the numbers that I'm getting are are these for the for the steps of of of two and minus three.
Again, it's parsing a grid and I'm getting key numbers here that are looking like one one extra.
I'm getting three three kinds of key numbers. So I put a circle around that around these every third one.
One, two. Twenty three and three seventy seven.
And then I'll put a square around the next guy or next let's put a triangle around it.
So that's one five sixty six. And there will be some guy down here and then then there's another one here which I can use a Oh a box.
OK. So that's one nine one thirty six and so on.
We'll be over here. So. So these, these,
these are the extreme numbers that that are there are the cases where corresponding
to AVC and BNZ before these are the cases where where we want to subtract three,
but we can't because we're too close to the origin. So so we get three policies in this case on that now, too.
And what end what are those power series AC, BFC?
And it turns out they we have to factor a polynomial and the polynomial is a Z.
You do the fifth minus you cube plus a Z.
And this has five factors. You minus use zero, you minus you one, you minus you two and then square it izzi you minus square to Z you three.
And square root of C you minus square is you four where you use zero one and two are equal to zero.
The one third time's the the generalized binomial of Z to the five.
Third to the one third power. And and you four and five are one over Z to the one half B B of five halves of Z to the five halves.
To the one half. In other words the here I have have another example of fractional five.
Third very tres five have very trees and and I get three of these because I choose three different cube roots of,
of Z here and I, I get two here because I choose two different square root.
So when you look, when you multiply these terms together, it turns out that you get all integer coefficients.
I mean, all I call a coefficient. Go away and you multiply these two together again.
You get all integer coefficients, all the fraction disappear.
The numbers that that you get are the numbers that that appear in the extremes of this problem and the numbers that you get.
In the other case are the numbers that you get in the extremes of the of the problem where you had minus three and plus two instead of I'm sorry.
Plus three and minus two instead of plus two and minus three.
Because if you consider a club, the people you tutor, time reversal, people come in threes and leave in twos.
It's the same number of way out of scenario. Except in the reverse order.
So. So this is the this is this is the fascinating theory.
And I've I've run out of time, so I just want to show you what what else is on the transcript that you see on the on the Web.
There is a particular problem is discussed in the paper by by my vendor to inflict gradually.
And they and they show they show the pattern of numbers there.
And then they they say now here's the number of scenarios for the for the club.
Dealer to 23. And these numbers are the so-called new Shole number.
And show is a person that I have not met.
However, he wrote a a very interesting paper discussing this particular problem.
And and I hit it.
And he had a completely different formula for that, for those numbers that he derived by using context, free grammar.
And what he does is he takes he gets it as a sum of these binomial coefficients here, which which are not even easy to to believe are integers.
In fact, in order to prove that they're that they're integers.
I have his formula here. Take cops, go zoom in and this does it.
This is the binomial five and plus two KHK and so on and so on and divided by five in Pliska.
So this is a I call it. Do short term end in case.
And it's a product, the binomial coefficient divided by something.
And. And he claimed it's an injury, but it's not at all easy to prove.
Now here I found another formula which explains why it's an integer.
Because I read it as a sum of four terms, each of which is obviously an integer, and call that all to do some term.
OK. And then do shop number is the sum of the douche on terms of from Kagel zero to N.
And so here's here's Duchamp's paper. Right. And, and I showed it.
I found a reason why it's an integer. And also then I, I now we can calculate with the my scenario on the transcript.
I calculated the the Duchamp.
Well I didn't show you the do something. Oh. Okay.
Well anyway I think you can play with it and try lots of ends and Kades and you'll see that, that they do actually check up to be equal.
And and so it comes out that, that his formula does work.
Now there was another paper that these guys were unaware of.
That was published in an obscure journal called the the Journal of the Institute of Actuaries in 1954.
And that is not a staffer's library. But I am sorry, but I checked it out and got it from Berkeley Library.
And this was this was before the state of California ran out of library budget, 1954.
They had and end up and isn't it in the paper.
Amazing paper by a guy named Michael Terence Lewis Bisley.
And here's the title of his paper. And it turns out that he actually discusses the do show numbers in his paper.
And and he has a completely different formula for the for the number of which has nothing to do with these polynomials I've been showing you at all.
And that the Bisley formula, which is the exponential of of the sum of binomial coefficients of this form of rather simple formula.
And and so if I had more time, I would explain to you why that works.
But but in fact, it the reason is, is something about the general binomial called.
Missions that I did not know before, and it qualifies as a as a as a brand new theorem about trees, I think.
And that is something that I just added to took till the next printing of concrete mathematics.
It's going to have a new graffiti all in the margin of page two, a one.
It says, newsflash that the natural log of the Out of Bisa script piece of t hack has actually this really simple formula, binomial coefficient.
Teekay over K divided by each the K over t.K. And and you know, all my life I've been playing with CATALIN numbers that even when T equals two,
I didn't know this formula for the logarithm Keadilan number. I showed it to people who are specialists in this and it was new to them.
And then I. And then after that, an hour after I, I reached them, I found it in my own book.
So, so. So I turned to volume volume two.
And there's an exercise in one of the darker corners there. On page five thirty five, I have a a a a formula and I didn't know it.
When I answered this formula that's what. Exercise twenty two.
It's, it says that I. I said, well you know anytime we have a generalized function like this, like it's logarithm also it's gonna be pretty nice.
And and so. So I found out to my surprise that I, I could have known this formula years ago, but.
So I guess summarize then there's still new things under the sun and amazing coincidence out there.
Beautiful patterns and numbers that bring together thing that we know you would never think were connected.
And if I had more time, I would show you an application to probability.
There were. It turns out that you can use the three halves.
I'll just give you a one one hint of it. Consider P times.
Q to the one half. This is Piers is a probability.
And Q is equal to one minus P. And in general, I'm gonna be interested in P to the AQ, to the B and as as P goes from zero to one.
This, this goes up and then goes down because when P is zero zero and B is one to zero and
so total victo at every point here except at that extreme where the double root,
there are two values that p p to the A, Q to the B is also equal to P hat to the A Q had to the B for some P had what you give me P
and I can then P hat is gonna be made and it gives corresponding one minus P had is going to,
is going to have the same value of here. So, so, so,
so there's just this interesting Mure relation and it turns out that I have a formula that will calculate
P hat in terms of the B the three halves function and and the that's illustrated at the very end of these.
At the end here I, I, I. See, eye out.
This is a little out of out of order here, but I calculate the P hat when P is one is point three.
And I get this number point three, six, seven. Sorry, it took a while to compute the function.
Mathematica was reading input before I got this answer.
OK, so. So then I input and I asked for that.
The head of this guy which was zero point three again. And then I asked for the same thing.
The mayor made two point seven. And the inverse me.
So. So the formula for calculating these PS and Qs is in the is in the mathematical file that I gave you in.
And it shows that there's an easy way to solve this probability problem.
OK. Merry Christmas to all.